nasim telev is one of my favorite
twitter followers even though he's a
he's a bit you know
cantankerous yeah he's cantankerous yeah
he's he's he annoys people for sure but
you know you want to hear the truth you
gotta you gotta be prepared to to be
hurt a little bit but he had a great
tweet recently that i retweeted which
i'm sure made a lot of people mad where
he said the opposite of education is not
ignorance the opposite of education is
in education and social
science science is the belief in the
ignorance of experts
and it's so funny because these days you
know so many people are on twitter
saying believe in science or according
to science and you've realized there's
no such thing as science with a capital
s
science the foundation of science is
doubt it is all about falsifiability
david deutsch who's kind of one of my
current modern living physicist heroes
is a properion like he he subscribes to
karl popper's philosophy and he
basically says that
you know if it's not falsifiable it's
not scientific if you can't prove it
false if there's if if you if it's true
up or down or left or right it's not
science um it doesn't require belief you
should be able to challenge it at all
times it should make risky predictions
that are not obvious and those
predictions should then be tested and
you shouldn't be able to after the fact
change the goal move the goal post or
change how the you know how the
predictions were set up
and so those are the hallmarks of good
science falsifiability independent
verifiability and making risky and
narrow predictions with details that are
hard to vary both before and after the
fact and that's how you end up with good
science and good explanations not by
people on twitter voting that's politics
so like everything has become politics
now science has become politics too
people politicized and there's big
science but i think feynman would be
very unhappy with that although he was
just a generally happy character and
non-political intended not to get
involved in these things but i think he
would realize that that is not actually
science but it's it's masquerade's a
science it's almost becoming social
science
and you know going to twitter like
nassim taleb is one of my favorite
twitter followers even though he's a
he's a bit you know can
yeah he's cantankerous yeah he's he's he
annoys people for sure but you know you
want to hear the truth you gotta you
gotta be prepared to to be hurt a little
bit but he had a great tweet recently
that i retweeted which i'm sure made a
lot of people mad where he said the
opposite of education is not ignorance
the opposite of education is an
education and social science
and uh i thought that was hilarious uh
but you know it hurts because there's
some truth to it if there was no truths
to it it wouldn't hurt at all you know
if i said tim ferriss is fat that would
just bounce right off of you but if i
said you know tim ferriss and of all or
fake gurus that might hit us right
because i suspect there's some deep
level there's a part of that that's true
so i think the same way like with you
know social science does kind of lead
you down the road to ignorance because
it's about social and anything social
is about group think and group behavior
and you know individuals can search for
truth but groups search for consensus
because if a group doesn't have
consensus it can't get along if it can't
get along it falls apart and there's
conflict and so the last place you're
going to find truth is in large groups
and the moment you make science about
large groups and about voting and about
consensus you're not really practicing
science anymore yeah and the science
with the capital s is dangerous
very dangerous
yeah it's propaganda it's and
it then it becomes like macroeconomics
again another nut until that line he
says it's easier to macro than
it's a micro and so
big science is the equivalent of
macroeconomics whereas the equivalent of
microeconomics of little science which
is you know me in a lab or me with my
computer and trying out various things
and so you can just like with
macroeconomics you can pick and choose
whatever data you want to prove whatever
point you want with big science you can
pick or choose whatever papers you want
so look at the fights right now on the
internet about what covid means you can
go down that hall of mirrors and find
scientific quote-unquote substantiation
for
many points of view depending on which
papers you choose to cherry-pick and so
then we reduce back to consensus but
again science isn't done by consensus it
should be done by experimentation
verifiability falsifiability rigorous
testing and you know in an ideal science
world you don't go and survey 10 000
scientists you actually pick the one
smartest scientist
but that's very hard to do now no one
can agree on who the smartest scientist
is so unfortunately i think that the
nature of what science is is being
corrupted and that started the day we
let the so-called social sciences
masquerade as sciences
you know the day we said psychology is a
science and politics can be a science
and and so on and you can apply the
scientific methods to those things then
i think that's the day we start to
corrupt science or at least the word
science so real science you know these
days is relegated to a very small corner
you know physics maybe like molecular
biology and chemistry mathematics theory
of computation but it's a fairly limited
set yeah yeah
very
quantitatively
uh
literate friend of mine said at one
point most of the disciplines that have
science at the end of them are not
actually science
exceptions right so yeah computer
science computer science science
if it's hard neuroscience
might be an exception but very often if
there's science appended to it it is not
in fact something that is falsifiable
according to someone like karl popper
right it cannot be
it cannot be proven or disproven using
experiment at least that's right
if there isn't some experiment could
that could theoretically disprove it
then it's not science um
yeah it's like honest abe's law firm
right he if he needs to put honest in
the title then you have to wonder
so the same way with science in the word
other than as you said computer science
and neuroscience you sort of have to
wonder well let's look at a couple of
quotes from feynman uh there are few
that
i think about a lot and these these are
on goodreads but
number one
and i think this is really applicable
with respect to
science in media particularly a term
that bothers me a lot which is studies
prove or studies show just like capital
s science
shows which isn't really a thing
the facts can get contorted quite a lot
the quote from feynman is i learned very
early the difference between knowing the
name of something and knowing something
right yeah
this is a very deep point and i think
that a lot of times that we just define
something with another definition or we
just throw out a piece of jargon as if
that means we know something and you
know it's a difference between
memorization and understanding
understanding is the thing that you want
you want to be able to describe it in 10
different ways in simple sentences from
the ground up and rederive whatever you
need if you've just memorized you're
lost so i think this is one of the
things that i get stuck on a lot which
is like just keep going back and reading
the basics over and over trying to
understand them
so don't necessarily have that tall
edifice of knowledge that is very
seductive in academia but as anyone
who's operated much in the real world
knows in the real world you get paid for
making good judgments and decisions
based on the basics for example if you
know arithmetic statistics probability
at a high level
and you understand some basic math you
have all the math that you need to
succeed in life you don't need calculus
or even trigonometry or number theory or
set theory or any of these kinds of
things unless you're going into a deeply
technical field or mathematics
yet we spend so much of our time in
school covering pre-calc and calculus
when the kids who are taking those
courses aren't even that good at basic
math
so the basics are really important
that's the steel frame the foundation
for understanding that you need to get
through life
and uh too much of it is reduced to
memorization and understanding things as
names and as definitions
and i think the feynman example is you
know his dad would take him for walks
and they would see birds and you know if
his dad would say this bird is such and
such a warbler but that doesn't tell you
anything about the bird that tells you
about humans and humans gave that bird
that name really the bird you know it
likes to stand on one leg at this point
it likes to pick it uh lice and it's
feathers doing this and it likes to eat
these kinds of things and it flies you
know this way for that reason and these
are its predators and these are its prey
so i mean those are the kinds of things
that really give you understanding who
cares what the bird is called
the name of the bird is irrelevant and
and you see a lot of professions in
professional life this happens a lot
which is jargon people try to protect
their knowledge by basically saying well
i understand this term and that term and
what this term means but the reality is
most people don't actually know what
these things mean underneath i find this
very common in accounting a lot of
business people don't know accounting
and even a lot of accountants will have
fancy words for things but when you dig
underneath they don't really understand
the principle of what's going on below
it and if you just understand the
principles and even if you don't
understand the words you will have an
advantage in for example negotiating
deals uh because you'll understand
underneath how the pieces are actually
moving on the board as opposed to what
they're called and i just want to point
out developing that
foundational
knowledge
is akin to learning the basics of
shooting foul throws in basketball it is
not becoming michael jordan right with a
very limited set of colors with which to
paint if you spend a few weeks
maybe not even a few weeks a few days
with a decent
youtube tutorial or book gathering the
basics of accounting you will be able to
make significantly better decisions
right i mean it's it's i just want to
underscore that this is not a
master's degree or phd or any type of
commitment like that that can separate
you from the pack in terms of advantage
well just just run a business uh run
lemonade stand will teach you better
accounting not a textbook now you may
need to learn certain conventions
because you need those to communicate
with other humans so that there's
efficient communication when you say one
thing they understand that thing and
that's where jargon can be useful
because it can be a compressed way of
communicating knowledge rather than
having to you know try and explain it
from first principles every time
but when it's not useful is when it
becomes a substitute for understanding
understanding is a thing you know that's
what separates
humans from the other animals that's
what separates us from the robots that
we actually understand what's going on
underneath like for example in the
artificial intelligence world there's a
new algorithm gpt3 which is the rage
which is text completion so people are
saying hey i can make up like really
plausible sounding writing and so the ai
is here is going to take all the jobs
well no because the ai doesn't actually
know what's going on underneath if i
were to ask it a question well why did
you write that uh or what does that mean
it would very quickly fall apart so you
always want to strive for understanding
not for memorization
you should be able to rearticulate it
five different ways in every language
that you know otherwise you don't really
understand it and the good news is you
don't have to understand
that many things you know while we're on
the topic of find a fineman
one of the phrase the quotes from him is
he says like you know nature uses only
the longest threads to weave her
tapestry
and so what he means by that is that
there's only a few basic principles that
you have to understand to kind of
understand the sum total of our
knowledge in physics there's not a lot
and as physics becomes more and more
advanced we're actually unifying
theories we're collapsing them into one
thing like we do with electricity and
magnetism or statistical mechanics and
heat and thermodynamics you know those
turn out to be one thing so we're or
we're trying to do currently with
gravity and quantum mechanics we're
trying to reconcile them in quantum loop
gravity or in string theory or what have
you so you just kind of have to
understand a few of the basic things and
then you'll see them recurring over and
over and over again like for example i
study and read physics in computer
science just for entertainment i don't
there's no practical application for me
but there's this really interesting
theory i was reading about called
solomonoff induction
and it's basically formalized as occam's
razor which is that the shortest answer
is the correct one
but it's it's more advanced than that
but it basically says like if you want
to figure out why something happened you
take all the different reasons why it
could have happened all the different
theories why it could have happened and
then you sort of
weigh each of them based on how
compressed they are how how short they
are how likely they are and then that
gives you the probability that kind of
gives you the the explanation for why
that theory happened now feynman has a
very similar and elegant thing in a
completely different field where he
basically says if you want to understand
why this particle took that path why did
this photon take that path what you do
is you look at all the possible
paths that photon could have taken and
you sort of weigh them you you sum them
probabilistically based on how likely
that path was it's actually the same
observation except one is about photons
traveling through space-time and the
other is about the causality and why an
event may have happened and what the
theory is behind that and these are two
completely different fields and two
completely different characters thinking
about two completely different things
and these are very very fundamental
theories in their fields but deep down
they're actually the same
which to me is fascinating it just shows
how much of what we look at as
complexity actually emerges from a set
of very simple rules
and it's just fascinating so
understanding is the thing to strive for
not the words so even though use the
fancy words like solomon of induction
and
and finance path integral theory
whatever the heck it's called i don't
even know what the actual name is the
name is irrelevant it's the concept
that's that's fascinating
[Music]
you